تعهد رئيسا الولايات المتحدة وكوريا الجنوبية
العام الماضي بتوسيع
التدريبات العسكرية المشتركة التي قالوا إنها لمواجهة
التهديد المتزايد من كوريا الشمالية،
وهذا بالضبط ما يفعلونه من
سفينة إلى الشاطئ لطحن
القوة القتالية والمعدات أثناء
محاولتهم الحفاظ على عنصر
المفاجأة هي أن
كوريا الشمالية تتفاعل دائمًا مع فكرة قيام
مشاة البحرية الأمريكية والكورية الجنوبية
باقتحام شاطئ في شبه الجزيرة الكورية، وترى
بيونج يانج أن هذا بمثابة بروفة
للغزو، والآن
أصبح الخط الكوري الجنوبي والأمريكي دائمًا هو أن هذا
أمر دفاعي.  في الطبيعة
2500 من مشاة البحرية الأمريكية والبحارة 3000 من
مشاة البحرية والبحارة الكوريين الجنوبيين يعملون
معًا في تدريب مشترك واسع النطاق، حيث تجلب
وسادة الإنزال الأمريكية أو
LCAC لإظهار كل ما هو مطلوب
للمراحل الأولى من المعركة، والآن
لم نر هذا  مستوى التدريبات في
شبه الجزيرة الكورية بعد خمس سنوات،
جولات متعددة في جميع أنحاء دولة
كوريا الجنوبية، يتم إجراؤها على الأراضي
في البحر وفي الجو،
حصلنا على وصول نادر خلف الكواليس
لهذا التدريب بالطيران إلى
سفينة الهجوم البرمائية الأمريكية  جزيرة يو إس إس ماكون
على خلفية
إطلاق الصواريخ الكورية الشمالية والادعاءات المتنازع عليها حول محاكاة
تجارب الأسلحة النووية تحت الماء، هذا تدريب ستتم
مراقبته بعناية في بيونغ يانغ، نحن على بعد
حوالي 30 عقدة لكل ميل من الشاطئ في
هذه المرحلة وهذه واحدة من
الحقائق L التي يتم تحميلها الآن
جاهزة للهبوط البرمائي،
وحدة المشاة البحرية الثالثة عشرة مخصصة للاستجابة
السريعة لأي نوع من الأزمات
العسكرية أو الإنسانية المكتفية ذاتيًا
وغالبًا ما تكون أول من يصل في
حالة الطوارئ ولكن بخمسة-  فجوة في التدريب لمدة عام
بسبب فيروس كورونا
والجهود الدبلوماسية السابقة مع كوريا الشمالية،
هناك عنصر من عناصر اللحاق بالركب،
كان علينا أن نبدأ من الأساسيات مرة أخرى،
هناك بعض الأشياء التي نعيد تعلمها،
أعني أن الأساس هو الاتصالات العدالة
بين  السفن بين الطائرات ثم
شريك أو حليف هنا في هذه المنطقة،
يبدو أن التحركات العسكرية لكوريا الشمالية
ليست محور التركيز الرئيسي هنا، فهي في
منطقة مهمة من العالم
في الوقت الحالي ولكنها روتينية وقد تم
تحديد موعد لها وقد فعلنا ذلك  مرات عديدة، لذا فإن
حقيقة أن هذه الأشياء تحدث
من حولنا حقًا، فإن تركيزنا هو فقط
ممارسة التشغيل البيني وهو
المصطلح الأكثر استخدامًا خلال هذا التمرين الذي يعمل على
مناورات أمريكية كورية سلسة، لقد
اعتدنا على هذا الآن، لذا إذا كان علينا القيام
بذلك بشكل حقيقي  لقد فعلنا ذلك بالفعل، لقد
عملنا بالفعل مع
شاشة الجمهوريين ونعرف كيفية التعامل معهم.
عودة الولايات المتحدة إلى التدريبات واسعة النطاق في
منطقة تضم الحلفاء والخصوم على حد سواء.